[Music]
I'm a big believer in doing things that
make you uncomfortable so we we live in
a world that we want to be as
comfortable as we can and we wonder why
we have no growth we wonder why when the
smallest thing in our life gets
difficult we wonder why we cower and we
run away because we are kind of living
our I mean our whole life except that
way our whole life is a set set up in in
the path of least resistance we don't
want to suffer we don't want to feel
discomfort so the whole time we're
living their lives in a very comfortable
area there's no growth in that so for me
I realized that the reason I became 297
pounds is because that was comfortable
what was very uncomfortable was running
was very uncomfortable was being on a
diet was very uncomfortable was trying
to face things that I didn't want to
face and I also realized when I was
really big I had no growth why because I
was living comfortable so I realized for
me to find growth I had to face all
these different things that made me very
very uncomfortable one thing I faced was
running I absolutely hated running but I
knew for me to grow I wanted I had to do
this thing every single day I want to
start callus in my mind I wanted to
start becoming a better person and how
you become a better person how you
gained mental toughness how you become
the person you want to be it's
constantly facing the things that you
don't want to face if you constantly run
away from things that you don't want to
face how is their growth how is their
mental toughness I can give you a class
all day long about self-talk
visualization eat an elephant one bite
at a time but if you're never putting
yourself in a situation to actually
practice these things you're never going
to grow I can't put you out there in a
we're all going through a battle in our
mind a warrior is not a person that
carries a gun the
biggest warrior ever go through is right
between your own ears it's in your mind
we're all going through a war in our
mind and we have to callus our mind to
fight that war and to win that war
so one example I can give you about
chaos in your mind about doing things
that make you uncomfortable there's a
there's a book out there called lone
survivor and there's a guy named marcus
luttrell he was on an operation where a
bunch of guys died and I knew all the
guys that died and I knew mark I know
marcus luttrell very well this story
touches my heart and I basically went
out there found a foundation to raise
money for it call the Special Operations
Warrior Foundation you give a hundred
percent tuition for let's say your dad
died in the war he was a special
operator if that guy had a kid you'd get
a hundred percent tuition to go to
college great foundation great people
working at the foundation I'm going to
do this so I googled the ten hardest
races in the world and at this time of
my life I was not a runner I maybe ran
10 miles the whole year I was into
bodybuilding I was into weight training
and that's what I did so I google the 10
hottest races in the world and what came
up number one was his race called the
bad water 135 so hundred thirty-five
mile race through Death Valley in the
summertime so I wanted to get in this
race I thought it was actually a stage
race I thought was a race where you ran
like 20 miles set up a camp and then ran
20 miles the next day I didn't know
people ran 100 miles and three five
miles at one time you know I know it's
even possible I had never run a marathon
so I called the race director up his
name is Chris Kaufman and I called him
up on a Wednesday and he and this is in
November he said David to qualify for my
race you have to do 100 miles and I said
hundred miles in a calendar year I
didn't know what's going on
he said no 100 miles in 24 hours or less
and I thought that was humanly
impossible he said so you got to do that
in 24 hours or less for me to consider
you in my race because there's a race on
Saturday and I called him up on wins
was that four days for me to get ready
for this race and I run ten miles a
whole year and so he said if you qualify
if you do 100 miles 24 hours or less I
might consider you my race so four days
later I'm out there in San Diego and the
in the race was called the san diego one
day where you run around a 24 or around
a one-mile track for 24 hours to see how
many miles you can get and so I go out
there then I didn't know I was doing
have mile place and Ritz crackers and
had a blue lawn chair that's all I had
and I was gonna see my crew person every
single mile and I could drink mile Plex
and have a rich cracker
they had no water had nothing went out
there got to mile 20 wasn't feeling too
bad around mile 30 I started feeling my
my my shins starting to get extremely
sore and I started to develop stress
fracture shin splints I started feeling
the metatarsals and my feet starting to
break at around mile 50 by mile 70 I was
totally destroyed and I sat down in this
blue lawn chair and I was destroyed and
when a bigger person sits down I don't
know exactly how much I weighed but I
was extremely I was extremely big I was
a power lifter lifted a lot of weights
and I was not an endurance athlete by
any means so I sat down this blue lawn
chair looked at my crew person and I
literally couldn't stand up I was
destroyed and I couldn't go in the
bathroom I had I well I couldn't stand
up to go to the bathroom so I sat there
and I went to the bathroom myself I was
destroyed and I was turning I was
discolored
I was pale I was dizzy lightheaded I was
in the worst shape of my entire life
I've been in three whole weeks Ranger
School all these different training
programs and this was the worst
situation I've been in my entire life I
thought I was literally dying and all I
could think about was how can I get out
of this chair I have 30 miles to go and
everything I had gone through I realized
that the human
mind if you can put it in a very quiet
calm place and get it to calm down and
not be so spastic that you could
possibly make this work out for you how
bad how bad are you really so I calm
myself down and I had to make this
enormous thing small I had 30 more miles
to run and my body was in the worst
shape in my entire life the worst pain
ever felt my life so I broke this 30
miles thing down I broke it down into
small chunks I calm my mind down I had
to get water how to get potassium how to
get sodium I had his to stop being so
dizzy because I had to be able to stand
up
so my disneys went away after about an
hour I was able to stand up now and I
was going around this track and like 37
minute mile and I'll never forget my
crew person saying hey I got tomorrow 81
they said you're not gonna make the time
I had 24 hours and I was going so slow
taking so much time this is when I
realized that the human mind once
everything gets connected once the mind
knows you're not going to quit something
it's gonna try to find more it's going
to try to give you more once it realizes
you're not going to take the path of
least resistance you're going to stay
here until it's done
my mind and my body my spirit became one
for the first time ever for the first
time ever it became one and I went to a
level that I never thought was humanly
possible for myself or anybody else in
that shape that I was in I was able to
run 19 miles and I ran 19 miles into 100
miles actually did one more mile I did
101 miles in 18 hours and 56 minutes it
overcome so many obstacles in my life
and this was the final crucible for me
and I got through it and at the end of
this race with such clarity to me and it
was just the most amazing thing I ever
do my life
[Music]